each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so first off I have to apologize usually
I'm not the front man I in the back end
programmer the front man is Santa ninja
and he is at a different conference so I
am the poor replacement I will make this
as brief and painless as possible I
promise so essentially what we do is we
want to study how do you safely
sequester co2 and why do you want to do
that and of course the fact that you
want to do something in the real world
and you want to simulate it implies that
you actually have to get data from the
field so your simulations your reservoir
characterization your studies are data
driven from actual sensors in the field
first off why do you want to sequester
co2 well it's very simple we need energy
and to get energy we burn fossil fuels
you can look at oil coal and gas and
they're the top three in terms of our
fuels that we consume in order to
produce energy and of course this trend
is increasing it's unlikely that it will
change until a couple of decades from
now now burning fossil fuels naturally
to co2 carbon dioxide and you want to
remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere or at least scrub it somehow
because it's a greenhouse gas one of the
ways you can do that is very simple you
sequester it in geologic formations this
is advantageous for many reasons one of
them is well you will reduce co2
emissions at one stage you actually
might end up with carbon neutral power
plants that burn coal or oil or gas the
other thing is if you sequester co2 you
can actually use it for enhanced oil
recovery you actually wash the rock
clean of oil and gas by injecting lots
and lots of carbon dioxide now the
geologic formations where you actually
want to sequester co2 in
they can have many characteristics but
most importantly you want you want them
to be able to hold the carbon dioxide
safely environmentally and geologically
meaning you don't want the co2 to
actually change the formation
drastically so it's unstable if you
don't want sinkholes and you don't want
the rock to fracture because that will
lead to co2 going places where it
shouldn't for example the water table
now reservoirs that are depleted as and
you can't get any more oil and gas from
them they're very good candidates why
very simple they're porous they can
actually hold stuff underneath there
impermeable to the surface so if you
pour down co2 if you inject co2 it won't
bubble to the surface the other thing is
we already have a lot of existing
infrastructure in terms of Wells tubing
and just to give you a perspective on
typical Wells what we call vanilla wells
are 10,000 feet deep the deepest well in
the world is the z11 well in Russia and
it's 37,000 feet that's seven miles the
well that she'll drill is drilling
actually right now they're still
drilling it of the Gulf of Mexico's
think 20 miles off of Galveston is
22,000 feet deep they are going to lay
down around 180 two miles of piping just
to produce that well you can use the
same infrastructure to actually inject
co2 so it's a lot of investment in
hardware just putting the tubing the
pumping stations the separators on the
ground and you can use them reuse them
for co2 the other thing is we really
know what those reservoirs look like
because we spend lots of time and energy
characterizing them we're on everything
from well tests pressure load up tests
we do seismic in a lot of seismic over
these wells just to find out how far
does the well go where should you inject
where should you produce how long should
you inject how long should you produce
what materials do you use do you use
surfactants do you use enhanced oil
recovery what kind of rock it is and all
of this information is gathered
tabulated and kept on the record for
many people for many people the
company's the production company and of
course the US government because they
really want to know what you're doing
that all of this information that we
gather is still very scarce usually your
field extends miles in length and width
and a few hundred feet sometimes more in
depth but what you get in terms of
actual information is rather limited we
don't get a lot of rock cuttings from
the sea formation underneath to the
surface we only get what we actually
drill so if you drill a hole that's this
big this is and let's say the formations
few hundred feet a few hundred feet x a
wall a diameter on an area of a circle
let's say a couple of feet or in
diameter that's all the rock cuttings
that you get to the surface and a lot of
it is deformed by the time it actually
gets to the surface because you're
circulating mud you change properties
because of heat because of pressure
moreover you can actually do core
samples you can actually lower tools
that eat away at the rock and then pull
them up and you can examine the rock and
you actually see what it looks like
according as you can imagine it's very
expensive and you cannot do it in oil
based muds so a lot of time in the deep
wells it cannot be done we don't have a
lot of information to go by so how do we
characterize the actual reservoir we do
history matching we don't run one
reservoir model we run hundreds and we
try to match what those reservoir models
give us in terms of production in terms
of oil flow rate water flow rate
pressures with actual production we see
from the field and that's how we know
those models are relatively accurate how
do we do the history matching while many
tools are available one really nice
approach is the use of ensemble common
filters these are the same ensemble
kalman filters you can use for radar
systems you can use them for a hurricane
tracking
you can also use them for reservoir
history matching so you start off with
lots and lots of fun samples lots and
lots of models further as water and your
humble and you hit a time where you
actually have production data usually
for vanilla type reservoirs that's every
week you have pressure readings from the
actual wellhead let's say you compare
your models what the models say you
should have in terms of pressures flow
rates bottom hole pressures compositions
etc with what you actually get from the
field based on that you modify your
models so that they adhere more closely
to the actual production and you repeat
this for the history for as long as you
have historical data of the actual as
well this is essentially what it looks
like you have model generation that's
when you start and you generate
statistically plausible models you don't
want rock formations that are impossible
because obviously that defeats the
purpose you have various models that
have different runtimes once you have a
historical data point that you can
assimilate data at you have a global
reduction operation where you actually
compute the common gain matrix you
change your models so the runtime
characteristics of those models change
and then you repeat now to do all of
this you need a few tools the tools
obviously our first off you need a
reservoir simulator or two in our case
we need to for various reasons we use
pet see the portal extensible toolkit
for scientific computing think of it as
a solver librarian will will revisit it
in a bit more detail later on we use
reservoir seem like we we need reservoir
simulator so we write them and we use
them on high performance computing
resources that is parallel parallel
machines supercomputers and we have two
reservoirs images we have cactus black
oil that is based on the Pepsi portable
sensible toolkit for scientific
computing package and the cactus code
framework for high performance
computing and of course defiant which is
based purely on pet see you also need
actual ensemble kalman filter the piece
of code that computes the common made
the common gain matrix and we didn't
we've written that because it's very
simple linear algebra we are written
that in pet see because Betsy handles in
your algebra in parallel so that's
advantageous and we need a way of
launching those models collecting the
data whenever we have historical data
point and launching them again and if
they are run on separate machines
pooling all this data or transmitting it
somehow to one local resource where you
actually have all the data available you
can run the common made the common
filter and just spread them out once the
common filter step is done so you need
workflow manager for that we used a saga
based fault tolerant autonomic workflow
manager and why is it fault tolerant
well very simple when you run typically
we run around 200 ensembles each running
on anywhere between sixteen sixty four
cores and we submit them to various
supercomputers almost always you'll have
one job that runs over the queue time
that is estimated and it gets killed and
you don't want to lose jobs along the
way you want everything to be there at
the end so it has to be fault tolerant
the last thing you need is a way of
getting data from the field to your
actual simulation that's why we use the
sensors to simulations framework that we
developed back in 2007 essentially think
of it as sensors streaming data to a
data spool which is in our case a MySQL
database using the prod ml the
production ml marker plank the
production markup language which is
standard for the oil industry and we
query the actual production data
whenever we can from the ensemble common
foot and more on that later so these are
the tools that we had to develop to be
able to do this and this is what the
closed-loop actually looks like we have
the job manager it launches the
simulations and if we actually have
action data to assimilate and use in the
common gain matrix calculation we
actually get it we get it from sensors
that actually collect from various
sensors in the field the building blocks
that we use for all these tools are as
follows we use a portable modular
extensible high performance computing
framework the cactus code framework
because as you can imagine we need
geochemists geologists reservoir
engineers all of those need to be able
to sit down at the same table and work
together it's very hard on us you have a
common platform that everybody can use
we use pet sea because it provides us
with parallel linear algebra provides us
with solvers preconditioners and
interfaces to various other packages for
example if we wanted to use algebraic
multigrid we can use the Boomer AMG
package from hyper underneath a patsy
interface to hyper and last but not
least we need an interface very a grid
interface that allows us to use
different resources that can be
distributed can be non-local can have
different architectures and be able to
transfer fat transfer files across those
different systems and tell an advert
service we have new data we don't have
new data we have to redo a couple of
simulations because they failed all of
that is provided through saga the simple
API for Grid applications now sample
results are palms I won't dwell terribly
on this this is a simulation of an
actual sand tank that we have at the
back of the petroleum engineering
department at LSU so actual sand tank
just big box with sand sensors on top
sensors at the bottom and what we're
doing is we actually filled it with
water and we're draining the water and
we actually calibrate our models based
on real-life data that we stream through
LabVIEW from the actual tank there is
calibration studies and of course the
case that we are currently solving the
SPE ten problem this is an espy ten a
comparative study problem for society
petroleum engineers and it's a layered
reservoir
very heterogeneous very an anisotropic
and we're trying to inject co2 at the
four corners and we're trying to produce
as much as as much oil as possible from
the center once the we produce less than
five percent oil we shut it off and we
keep we keep injecting co2 until the
model the actual formation fractures
obviously we don't wait until it
fractures we stop about fifty percent
the way there little bit more on saga
because I hazard a guess that's what a
lot of people are interested in soccer
the simple API for Grid applications it
is a new way to develop applications in
a sense that it allows programmers
software engineers people like me to add
grid tools and make their applications
grid enabled and add some autonomic
behavior to their applications without
having to deal with Globus really
complex api's and sorry to say this Java
it allows us to it allows me to use all
sorts of tools and technologies that I
need everything from transferring files
across machines inherently launching
jobs remotely doing everything that the
grid can everything that grid offers
with a very simple API furthermore it
actually allows me to do something more
it allows me to run on condor it also
allows me to run on the amazon ec2 and
if anybody was wondering had to spend
1402 dollars on the amazon ec2 and I
still haven't been reimbursed anyways
this is what it looks like architectural
a you have the saga runtime engine the
C++ API the Python API wrapper and the
capi wrap and currently what I work with
is the python api wrapper because it's
very small very compact and it's
portable you just move it anywhere where
you have a circa installation now this
is a run that is very interesting we
first started with saying okay we have
various computing resources we have
ranger attack where I
work we have queen bee at cct which is
the place i used to work and we have a
at NCSA and we thought let's try to
launch on all those three machines
together and see if we can get any
performance boost and the one we hold we
actually do so if we launch one Ranger
alone it takes us about 4,700 seconds to
finish a hundred simulations five
assimilation stages and eight cores per
simulation if we launched on quindi
alone it takes is obviously more and if
we look what we don't have a ballon but
if we launched on Ranger and Queen B
takes us significantly less than Rangers
alone and queen be alone furthermore if
we launched on Ranger Queen DNA we
actually get to the total time we
actually get a lower total time to
completion one thing we can also use is
the batch queue prediction system which
allows us to trick the submission
environment to thinking that we're
submitting jobs that are optimal and
should be run immediately obviously
system administrators were not very
happy when we told them that this is
what we were doing we were really
jumping the queues submitting jobs that
are tailored you just explicitly
tailored to run ahead of everybody else
because they were short inside and they
will large in duration and we actually
got a really good result we actually got
improvement using ranger queen bee and
Abe who would be QP because we don't
spend any time in the queue now this is
not terribly interesting for Co for co2
sequestration but when you think about
it for critical applications where you
actually have something critical
happening you have a sudden loss of
pressure in co2 you're injecting co2 and
suddenly from 5,000 psi at the injector
you drop down to 2,500 psi what just
happened you want to know where the co2
went you want to know if you fractured
the rock and you're injecting co2 in the
water table because what you're doing is
you're turning the water acidic and you
don't want to do that with fresh
and in the end of the day it really is
just a matter of scale this is the SPE
10 problem again suppose we have this
actually has 1.2 million cells but
suppose it has 1 million grid cells and
we have to use finite differences by the
way because oil and gas industry does
not believe in finite elements finite
volume or discontinuous galerkin
anything else they won't find a
difference they can understand that so
we do find the differences so 1.2
million grid cells they don't understand
adaptive mesh refinement either so we
can't reduce a number of whistles 1.2
million grid cells a thousand ensembles
that's a billion degrees of freedom
that's a lot degrees of freedom to solve
in one big dense matrix that is the
ensemble kalman gain matrix how do we do
it while we paralyze everything and we
try to scale out as much as possible so
we base our code on existing tools that
we know should scale and we keep doing
that whether scaling in hpc resources or
high throughput computing resources now
when I actually first started doing this
the guys started to laugh at me because
it so it's still a lot of thousand but
still that it gets the idea across
conclusions well very simply we need
abstractions because we need to do
things on a higher level than we
otherwise would we need parallel linear
algebra because dealing with the billion
degrees of freedom is hard and obviously
you need parallel computing nobody will
love you for running something that
takes a billion degrees of freedom out
of core on any of their machines you
need parallels were simulators because
you want to reach your result you want a
reduced total time to completion so you
have to use something that runs fast you
want distributed high throughput for
high-throughput capable fault tolerant
autonomic and optimized frameworks for
job managing bookkeeping keeping tabs on
where the simulations went all of these
tools we developed in addition you also
need other tools that we don't have
tools I do for example geochemical
interaction of co2 with brine
currently we actually have a team of
people working on this and so far
they're using cactus they're not
terribly happy they can't get their
chemical reactions to it properly in
peril we're all we will always have work
to do in terms of improving the
simulations improving the common game
currently for example the common the
ensemble kalman filter works very nicely
for very linear problems once you hit a
binomial function let's say the Buckley
Leverett problem in petroleum
engineering or a place where you have
short sharp drop offs or multi-component
fluid flow you have a problem because
the common gain the common matrix won't
with the comment the ensemble kalman
filter won't be able to isolate the
covariance matrix matrix is very clearly
you have to use something like an
iterative randomized maximum-likelihood
filter gets even more involved more
complex so work is in progress and we're
still going to do more in terms of
launching capability we can launch on
Terra great resources we can launch on
condor pools at purdue at ranger at
queen bee and we actually launched on
ec2 and eucalyptus at indiana and at
Amazon ec2 any questions
I will even take star trek trivia
absolutely sadly none we were just
pressed for time and we thought well how
do we do this quickly and we didn't
spend enough time investigating where to
run it so it's sort of the effort sort
of mushroomed out of control we started
using the Indiana you could look this
cluster soon afterwards but by the time
I actually started moved to eucalyptus
the damage was done and my credit card
was built so there wasn't much that can
be done in all honesty one of the things
that we want to look at is the use of
well so in cloud computing we actually
did in the cloud computing paper that we
published about this effort we used
various modes of usage for the ec2 for
clouds in general as accelerators to
help move the simulations along let's
say if for some reason they know what
guys decided to run on Ranger and you're
waking up in the queue you start a
couple of ec2 instances and you just get
stuff done while you're waiting and you
have an estimate on how much a job will
take based on previous history of the
job so you can get started with the look
with the low cost low hanging fruit on
the app on the cloud before you start on
the HPC resources the other one was on
the use of clouds as fault tolerant
mechanisms so if some something dies on
on the Terra grid and you want to launch
it again it will spend time on the queue
interrogate you just launched it on the
left on the cloud with all of this and
of course in terms of cost if it costs
you a lot of money to launch on the
third ready response launch it on ec2
all of this taken into consideration
having a commercial having a commercial
cloud is nice and everything but ideally
you want it done with a lower cost so if
the solution is critical if you need it
now working off the money to actually
get the solution
right now is worth it especially if you
have let's say an environmental crisis
on your hands and of course then you can
have the spruce guys calling and saying
well why don't you use spruce and tokens
for instant on computing and that's
about a point so the technology is that
we can use our well there's plenty of
them and making the right decision
sometimes can be daunting task